I mean I wish I had some weed
eating
yeah
[Laughter]
so so we're like
you'll be fine you'll probably do a
better job
because you're not high yeah
but no when I'm high I've been getting
into detail or like I feel like I'm
gonna cry like because you wouldn't be
the first
a lot of things have happened to me
you wouldn't be the first darling
all right Sherry
Cherry where did you grow up where are
you from I'm really but I've been around
like a lot
what part of that lady girlfriend
I grew up in Inglewood
Hawthorne
um yeah that's about it
you tell me about your family as a kid
um
well I was spoiled because I was at my
dad's only daughter
and
yeah I went to private school and
yeah I was really spoiled I was really a
brat I know I was
and my travel was really good you had a
mom and dad yes yes I have Mom and Dad
so it sounds like a pretty good
childhood yeah it was
okay were you in high school
um really
high school as a freshman I would I felt
like I was like really a
I'm not even gonna stay a follower but a
person that just like wanted to do it
every else girl wanted to do like have
their hair this like mine and stuff like
that like
are you a follower no I'm not a follower
I'm just saying like I wanted my hair
like theirs like
because like it was how my hair was when
I as a freshman in high school it was
like oh my God it's not like popping
like this so I'm like dang
and I was on like when I was freshman
it was like
it was a it was it was like a lot
because I changed
I changed as freshman I think that high
school really changed me
was like I never
act the way I acted as a 15 year old
before I went to high school like
and I
became angry and
like really selfish and I think about
myself a lot
what do you think you were angry about
that
I just didn't
sometimes like as me being like really
pretty and thick and having a big butt
like I just didn't fit in with the girls
like that didn't they didn't like me
some of the girls at the high school
didn't like me
or their their boyfriends would talk to
me or even look at me they were jealous
of you I think so we cannot think so
yeah
it was a lot High School is not easy
yes not
you graduated no you didn't
what happened
I
I went to juvenile hall I got in trouble
went to juvenile hall
because I fought my mom
because I felt like she wasn't helping
me you are defiant
and the reason why I did that because I
went to leave from the house that we
were in
because when I was 15 I got raped
before Mother's Day
and I walked on barefoot
and
it was
I just felt like she wasn't helping me
where did this happen
in California City but not not at home
it is something no you're out yeah I was
out
and I knew I shouldn't have went out
because I really like really traumatized
me like
after that happened
all I did was sleep all I did was
take showers and I couldn't like
like bare to like even like I don't know
like I just
it was just like I felt like I was in
the Shell once that happened to me
and like we went to the
doctors to see if like I had anything
from him
no I didn't
and she was just telling me like
the police is going to have to get
involved
because I knew what he looked like and
she I didn't want that because he knew
her we lived at the time in California
City and
detective came and he was just like
you're trying to protect him he's a
predator
he's been a predator
and I just didn't care I didn't want no
police to be involved in that
I understand why but can you explain why
because he knew where I lived on top of
that and then I have little sisters and
brothers like no is he in the game no no
no but but he hangs around with people
that had guns in yeah yeah that were big
in Cal City and I just didn't want that
so yeah
after detective left from our house
me and her was like I was telling her
like I want my stuff like I want to
leave
she was like mine don't go in my room
and I went there I tried to take my
stuff from her closet once I seen my
stuff in her closet
and
we just started to fight
and then I ran out the house
and I ran away in the classroom for me
when I came back home like at night time
she was like money where did you go like
I came because he already been told
as soon as I was there she knew I
knocked on the door that was me knocking
on the door and she told and then
I spent
a month and 10 days in juvenile hall
they actually helped me with whatever
that was going on with me
when that guy had raped me
they gave me
Prozac for depression and trazodone
because I couldn't sleep did that help
you
kind of when I was in juvenile hall it
was helping me because it was like a
drug like it was getting me high like
the trazodone was getting giving me
getting me high like every day I would
take it at night I would go straight to
sleep
and I just like kept asking for more
like
but then when I left out of juvenile
hall I still had to get
like I still have to get more
and they gave me they actually gave me a
higher dosage than what the last pills I
had of trazodone was because
I really couldn't sleep
couldn't sleep at home
yeah and drug use has continued for you
or no no there are pills there are pills
there I don't know but sometimes people
will Branch off into self-medicating
with
other drugs I do weed I smoke marijuana
that is it yeah it seems to be like
cigarettes nowadays yeah I know
I know it is and then somehow you ended
up
working the track
yes how did that happen
I was
I'm not even gonna lie
the my first pimp ever was when I I met
him when I was 17. he contacted me on
Instagram
and
I really was in love with him I really
wasn't loving him
and
yeah he basically
hit me up on Instagram asked me like
have you ever trapped before I told him
no
like I don't understand like I'm new to
this like what are you talking about so
one day we had really linked up we had
intercourse on the first day and I knew
I shouldn't have done that I knew I
shouldn't have done that because that's
when he asked me like he was just like
damn you got some good can I cuss
he was just like damn you got some good
coochie this and that I was just like
okay and and
I was just like and then he was just
like have you ever trapped before and I
was like no I don't know what that is
like run it down basically tell me the
basics of it and
I just was like
oh okay and then one day I was at the
store with my brother and he's blowing
my phone up
like yeah it's my location he's like
where are you at where are you at where
are you at I'm like what the what is
going on
and I'm like I'm with my brother he's
getting school clothes and he's just
like obviously you don't want to get no
money
and I'm just like what so then he was
like pack your stuff and I'm coming to
get you tonight and I was like okay
so we go like that day he already told
me he had court
like at nine something in the morning so
we leave
somewhere like
like in the in between Palmdale and
Lancaster I don't know what I don't know
what city that was
but we stayed in the hotel and he went
to go
like in the morning time like we went at
night to the hotel and he went to go
to court and he left me at the hotel he
was like get dressed and I was like okay
and my first time
my first time hauling was on in San
Bernardino on G Street in Spruce
and I really did well like I caught my
first date like in 15 minutes like just
standing here and I was just like I got
100 140 for head and I was just like man
what the heck so then he had
came and picked me up
and then we went to
Pomona
mind you I am wearing a black tube top
and some blue blue navy shorts with
holes in the back
see my ass like and then he was like
like he was just like I mean
it's he just he didn't care but it was
just like I did
like this is daytime I'm outside looking
like this in the daytime
but I got arrested
you got arrested yes like I'm 17. they
see me walking there every time it was
like it wasn't a cop but it was
Undercover
like as I'm walking across the street
they pull me like they like
as soon as I cross the street they were
like and I'm like what the heck I'm like
they're like stop right there I'm like
dang what did I do and then looking at
me like
oh we know what you are and then they're
like I'm like it's hot outside what are
you talking about I can't wear clothes
it's hot outside they're like
you're on a blade you're on a track
we know what you're doing
they went through my bags seeing condoms
and that's when
I was just like
this is how it's gonna be like why
should why would I do this
but he
he I don't know what he did after I got
arrested because
I went home they took me home the people
or whatever it took me home
and they basically told my mom
everything I was doing
and I did in the whole story I told them
but I lied though so they were never
going to find out who he was or anything
but
yeah
it was like three weeks I haven't been
with him
I finally hit him up he like
Oh I thought you left me I thought the
Mexicans took you and this and that he
was like I threw all your stuff away and
I was just like are you serious
those are my clothes I'm like dang those
are my shoes I had Nike shoes up in here
in that bag he said Oh I thought you
were playing with me and then he said I
thought that it was I thought um some
Mexicans took you and I had ran up in a
house I'm like you had ran up in a house
I'm like what are you doing he was like
I thought they took you and it was like
the last location
was at that spot and I was like was it
next to the police station he was like
yeah I'm like duh I was in the police
station like you're so weird
and
that day he came and got me
and
that was in August
he came and got me in August and then I
how many pimps have you had
I don't even want to say I don't even
want to say but it was it's a lot it's
not a lot I would say it was like five
because the reason why is because like
I don't like
they're
their whole program
I'll just leave is it easier for you to
get away
yes it is but
they be
right then I'll be having my stuff they
like oh you gotta pay to get your stuff
back yeah tell me tell me how you get
away from a parent
so this is how I do it
so basically
so this is how I do it so
I guess he puts me down I get ready puts
me down
obviously I I ha I don't make excuses
but I just be like
oh
oh this ripped on my on my clothes I
need to go change or something like that
and I was like
I'll say anything just to go back to
that room just to get just to leave
because I don't like that program
and then you run away
that there's no there's no you don't
have to pay anyone to get out or
anything like that well yes there's been
two times there's been two times where
that's what I'm talking about there's
been two times where
he was just like you're gonna have to
you're gonna have to give me my trapped
before you go home
before you get your stuff
and I mean like
their material things they're
replaceable but it's just like dang
I worked hard for that stuff you know
how much you have to pay to get away
from
sometimes it'll be like a 200 fee or
200. yes I've heard 10 times that I've
heard much more yes then there was a
five thousand five thousand that's what
I've heard yeah yeah
I was just like you know that is a
choosing fee though 5 000 that's the
choosing fee you have to pay to be
chosen you have to or when you choose
you have to pay and when you get away
you have to pay yep
it's a lot it's crazy yeah
it's a lot how does this kind of work
are you are you
independent now
right now I
I uh me and him are not talking
you're in limbo right now
um I'm at my mom's house right now oh I
see so me and we're not talking
he wants me back but
um
I feel like he has too much going on
and he
he's obviously in a relationship with
his BM
so I don't want to be involved with that
is your heart involved
do you have feelings for him
a little bit like he helps me because
like
another one I'm like really going
through something right now
to the point where
my mom she's crying because she doesn't
want me out there
she thinks that I'm gonna like die
how old are you I'm 18. 18.
she doesn't she doesn't like that she
doesn't want me to leave no parent wants
their 18 year old daughter doing this
I know
how does it affect you
emotionally
I mean when I hear my mom crying and
telling me she could do the best that
she can and she's trying to help me it's
like
it kind of hurts
but it's just like
my first pin
he changed me
like I feel like like being outside and
doing this
is a drug
like it's just
money is the drug you're addicted to the
fast money yes I am I hear that a lot
you're not the only one
I'm really addicted
it's not the sex it's not the
it's the it's the money yeah
you have I'm sure you have bad
experiences with the tricks I have in
August last year
I had a real bad experience
it like really opened my eyes
to like watch out for different tricks
and the red flags
yeah
this year
that was crazy that that had happened to
me it was crazy
like
I'm doing a date I'm on a date with this
Hispanic a red truck
where
we're like over there in Menlo parked up
I did my I did whatever I had to do
I told him to take me back to 65th he
didn't take me back to 65th he kept
driving
and
I was just like what is going on and at
the time this is my first time on fig
this is my first time on fig
and
this is when I was with my first pimp he
had left me
first time on fig
so he wouldn't take me to 60 50 kept
driving he'd drive past McDonald's
heading over to the 80s I'm just like I
told you can you take me back to 65th
as he's handing me the money I I I
forgot that you're supposed to
get the money first before doing
anything
I forgot
and as he's giving me the money
he's I get it I open my bag I'm like
thinking like are you gonna turn around
like take me back to 65th he's still
going
still going driving real real fast he
starts getting physical with me once I
open my purse he's seen all the money I
had in my purse he started getting
physical with me started like grabbing
me and all types of stuff I'm just like
scared out of my my [ __ ] mind I I
open his door through my phone through
my person jumped out jumped out of the
Guard
and that's how I got this these scars
right here this car right here I have
one on my back I have like a whole thing
on my arm and I was just I was I guess I
was on the floor I guess I was rolling
rolling rolling because on the floor
they the girl it was another girl on
80th she said I was she thought I was
dead
because I was laying on the floor She
said I was laying on the floor about
about five to ten minutes
and I got up luckily my personal phone
was like
still like in the street and my shoe was
on the other side of like the island
that's on 80th it was on the other side
of the street
and when I got up
my body
I was just like really shocked that
that happened and I didn't think of it
like oh I have scratches on me
but once I got to the sun and it hit my
body in the parts that were like open
and bloody and stuff I started to cry I
started to scream
because
it looked bad like how am I gonna catch
dates like this
it was disgusting like
and then the girl was like I seen
everything I seen everything she was
like are you okay she was like do you
want me to call my folks and I was just
looking at her like are you serious
like girl get away from me like what is
your problem you're trying to make me go
with your folks
I've just got into a whole car accident
I have I have a I have folks already
like don't do that
but
he
I'm I called him after that happened
he's like what are you talking about I
can't hear you I'm like come to 80th now
come say it is now I'm like walking back
and forth like don't know what to do
because I'm just like really scared of
what just happened to me like you're not
here you're not here
I'm just like where did you go he just
like oh it's my fault
I should have been here I'm just like
this is my first time on figging this is
what happened to me
this is what happened
I was like I'm scared I was scared to
figure I was like never never in my life
but I mean now I'm cautious
and yes he did take me to the hospital
you did yes he took me to the memorial
for how long
like and I started in July
of uh of last year and now so
um half nine months yeah
do you believe do you think you do
deserve better than this lifestyle
yes I do I'm really smart you see me I
am I really smart you're the only smart
female I've seen do do self-destructive
things I mean I'm not I'm not dumb I
just make dumb decisions yeah we all do
yes I make we all make a lot of mistakes
we're human
it's not a female thing it's a it's a
human thing yeah
what's the best thing that's ever
happened to you out there
um
I wouldn't want to say it was the best
thing I have
to have a lot of a lot of wisdom from a
girl
a girl that was on the track with me
I got a lot of wisdom would you learn
huh would you learn
I learned a lot
she basically told me
the whole
rundown of the game
and that
it has changed the game has changed
it has it's not the same she said it's
not the same
and
it's life
and a lot of things will happen to you
that's how you have to be prepared and
stay ready and you also have to have
that how do you say
that
that mindset of knowing like you're
gonna come out here you already know
what's going to happen
so
you have to be aware
I said she basically told me and that
I should Choose Wisely with
pimps
because there's pins that will really
man
a lot
more than any
Fields I've ever seen I think there's a
wide wide wide
range of temps yeah there is
whole Hustlers to the
the guys who actually make your life
better yeah not that working the streets
is a good thing for any female it's not
but
if that's the world you come from and
that's the culture you come from and you
don't have the ability to become a nurse
or a lawyer or teacher or anything like
that
you're going to do this work regardless
then there are pimps that can help you
do that safely and I mean the god the
person yeah the person I'm with right
now he is trying to help me
but I don't I he wants to help me
but I just don't want it from him
anymore like I just feel like I've Grown
Apart from him
that's what I haven't been talking to
him yeah just keep in mind you're you're
a young girl you're 18. you have your
whole life ahead of you
and
just be aware of where this lifestyle
will lead you
you know where you'll be in five or ten
years or 20 years
but I mean
your mom's probably not wrong
yeah she's not
she wants me to go to school
ask me to go to Community College and
get my GED to get a real job
what stops you from doing that
it's not stopping me
it's just like
I don't like being home it's not as fun
as yes it's not as like what am I going
to be doing I'm going to be doing work
all the time but it's like
I'm it's not paying me I have to pay
them
like that's out that is so out yeah if
you're not making money
I guess you could look at it so you're
paying the college the community college
or you're paying your phone either way
yeah that's out and after five years of
either you'll have a
or four years you'll have a diploma and
or you'll have what do you have with the
pen
what do I have after four years of
spending
man I don't know oh [ __ ] I don't know
I wouldn't really know if I chose the
right one if you chose the right one you
might actually have it yes that's right
but in La you have Slim Pickens
[Music]
I just paid all the good La temperatures
yeah I paid pimps and left the next day
because I just don't like their program
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned
in your 18 years
a lot don't feel like don't feel too
much pressure you're only 18.
I mean you seem pretty wise
um
I mean
I've learned to be
I learned not to lie a lot and be
consistent
with things that I want to do
I have to really bust my ass for a
lifestyle that I really do want
that you really do want yeah oh oh a
different path yes a different career
yes you're gonna have to bust your ass
yes I'm gonna have to that's a lot of
people in your generation I think don't
don't really want to do yeah
they're trying to find a shortcut
I don't know if there is such a thing
but I know I can
I can't do what I want to do
in life if I really try and put my all
into it because I know I could
do it
if I'm really out here doing this I know
I could do anything else
absolutely
all right Jerry thank you so much for
sharing your story okay you're welcome I
hope you make some good decisions for
yourself I am